your boss's office his name etched on
the frosted glass window in the door
sitting at the end of a long hallway he
called you in and you don't know if
you'll be leaving with your job a grimy
public bathroom filled with graffiti
spiders crack toilet seats and a
sinister shadow in the very last stall a
surgical theater where mass doctors wait
with gleaming scalpels forceps and bone
saws preparing for an operation that you
don't know if you'll wake up from all of
these have one thing in common their
rooms that inspire dread but after this
video you'll look back on all of them
like you would your cozy childhood
bedroom a wise man once said life has
many doors what he didn't say is that
sometimes opening the wrong door can be
a way of bringing that life to an
untimely end or worse especially when
you're dealing with the kind of
horrifying anomalies secured and
contained by the scp foundation you may
think it's what's lurking inside the
room that might be your biggest threat
but that's a potentially lethal
assumption sometimes the most dangerous
thing is the room itself and that's what
we're here to talk about today seven of
the most terrifying rooms on the
foundations database none of which have
ever been featured on this channel
before so reach out grab the handle and
open the door
welcome to the scp foundation's most
terrifying rooms all you can do is hope
that by the end you'll actually be able
to leave we'll begin with an old classic
from series one scp-002
a maleficent meatball known as the
living room there's a decent chance
you're sitting in your living room right
now while you watch this video so you
may be thinking what's so wrong about
that but this really is a living room
and it's always on the lookout for some
tasteful new furniture from the outside
scp-002 appears to be a huge tumorous
blob made out of living flesh sure that
may seem off-putting but don't be so
superficial the inside of 0-002 is a
different story it may appear like your
standard low-rent apartment from within
but this place has a lot of personality
there's a single window despite there
being no opening for a window from the
outside in addition to all the standard
furniture chairs tables a tv stand it's
actually developed a number of other
wonderful amenities since being
contained by the foundation including
two lamps a throw rug a television a
radio a beanbag chair three books in an
unknown language four children's toys
and a small potted plant the first thing
you might notice about the room is the
funny smell then you might take a closer
look at all that lovely furniture that's
when you'll realize that every single
piece of furniture in there is made out
of human tissue wood is polished in
varnished bone fabrics are woven from
human hair leather is made from tanned
human's skin this is what happens to
anyone who enters scp-002
and sadly if you've gotten close enough
to see this it's already too late we
hope you enjoyed the rest of your
existence as a brand new armchair but
maybe you don't want to get turned into
furniture inside a living room within a
giant tumor maybe you've got more
specific needs you like puzzles
exercises and most of all
solitude you like to test your mental
and physical fortitude without worrying
about the distractions caused by having
to deal with other human beings if that
sounds like you then let's get your feet
wet and tell you about a wonderful piece
of prime real estate you can find under
the sea scp-057
this underwater chamber is almost
impossible to get to without a james
cameron style mini submarine but believe
us it's worth the effort if you manage
to access
scp-057 and enter its submerged chamber
then you're going to be treated to the
best last challenge of your life the
door will close behind you permanently
ensuring that wonderful privacy you so
covet then the walls these impenetrable
monoliths of slate-covered stone will
begin to move like a kind of high-stakes
game show you'll need to keep moving
avoiding the ever-shifting walls as the
environment around you becomes more and
more disorienting there is no escape
only survival and survival is only
temporary when your body fails you or
your mind snaps under the weight of
sustained mortal terror that's when
those walls will close in the monoliths
of scp-015
will get closer and closer and closer
until your body is crushed between them
killing you with a torturously slow
squeeze where nothing and nobody will
ever hear your final choke screams but
it's all worth it for that glorious
ocean view
oh look at all those adorable little
fishies but hey maybe sea punk isn't
your favorite aesthetic maybe you're the
more industrial type you couldn't feel
more at home than among a complex
network of anomalous pipes we'll admit
that's eerily specific but it isn't half
as eerie as
scp-015 if you ever find yourself
opening the door to the main room of a
certain undisclosed warehouse you'll
feel like you've walked into an early
2000s screamsaver with a decidedly
gritty edge an impossibly huge and
intricate mass of pipes vents boilers
and other various plumbing apparatus
that just keeps growing seemingly
becoming more strange and anomalous as
it does so these pipes have been made
out of bone wood steel pressed ash human
flesh glass and granite there aren't any
pipes made out of traditional pipe
making materials like lead copper
ceramics or pvc and if you think what
the pipes are made of is weird the
materials that travel through them are
even freakier these include oil mercury
rats a species of insect not yet
identified ground glass seawater
entrails and molten iron and this is
important to remember because if you
appear hostile to scp-014 or enter the
room carrying tools the pipes will begin
to burst and spray you with their
contents in self-defense resulting in
one of the few times in human history
where you'd be incredibly lucky to only
be sprayed with rats or human entrails
much like scp-173 the sculpture it's
important to keep this room under strict
observation it's when the pipes are left
unoccupied that they start expanding and
trying to grow downwards in the hopes of
mixing with the sewer system below if
ever that happens then the pipes may end
up coming to a room near you and
considering that people have also
reported screaming coming from inside
the pipes what comes out of them may not
even be as frightening as what could be
going in but maybe you don't want a
warehouse perhaps you just want to rent
a small cozy room in a one-story
building over in weehawken new jersey
problem is if you try to do this you
might end up lodging in
scp-5256 a room that defies reality in a
number of freaky ways thanks to its
prior occupant a highly unstable reality
warper the reality filters get stronger
the further you go into the room with
the terminus being the room's far corner
which presents as an empty void that's
impossible to even see a damaged bloody
hammer is lodged into the far wall metal
fragments covered in human blood float
near the entrance half-eaten bugs all
over the floor there's a crucifix on the
wall along with medical grade
anesthetics with trace amounts of neural
tissue inside all evidence points to the
reality warper having being the victim
of atrocious and inhumane acts perhaps
as a way to cure it of its anomalous
affliction and to add to the creep
factor many believe its body is still in
there lurking in the unseeable corner
how do we know because despite the
corner of the room being unseeable
people have still performed simple
tactile tests by sticking their hand
into the space one d-class reported it
feeling like leathery flesh with
occasional scraps of fabric and sharp
needle-like objects occasionally
sticking out of its skin but for rent
this jeep who can really complain about
a body or two but that's enough about
things that are just creepy let's get to
dangerous instead a room that won't just
freak you out with some eerie anomalous
sights if you get unlucky it'll give you
a horrifying death after all who doesn't
like a little excitement step into
scp-4595
a small room and a wood shed behind an
abandoned house near jasper indiana
you'll be taken in by its rustic charm
at first it's a quiet peaceful setting
where you're alone with your thoughts
when the room was first found it
contained a small blood-stained shovel
and the skeleton of an adolescent male
but don't let that put you off don't let
the charcoal marking of the word witch
written on the exterior door bother you
either it all just adds to the character
of the room oh there is one thing we
should probably mention there is an
entity known as
scp-4595-a that lives a meter beneath
the room she's a witch-like creature
rotted and covered in wounds on her
torso and face her mere presence will
instill a sense of paranoia and dread
into getting worse and worse the longer
you're in there but stay quiet about it
if at any point you disturb scp-4595
all the empty spaces in your chest
cavity as well as your lungs airways
stomach and intestine will suddenly fill
with live desert locusts causing you to
experience a horrible death so be a
considerate upstairs neighbor or else so
remember when we said earlier that it's
not always what's inside the room that
can cause you harm sometimes it's the
thing right on the other side of the
door look at the nearest closed door
really focus on it tell us how can you
be so sure there's not something on the
other side can you hear its heavy
wheezing breaths it's not a home invader
it's something even worse
scp-303 and it can make any room
anywhere an absolute nightmare for you
keep an eye on that door while we
explain
scp-303 is a tall emaciated creature
with dark skin and no face
just a giant mouth twisted into a fixed
grimace of pain with unnaturally long
teeth nobody has ever seen its full body
but everyone afflicted with its
anomalous effects somehow has an innate
knowledge of exactly what they're
dealing with the amount of time that 303
spends behind the door seems to be
random but whenever it appears people
will be afflicted with such a level of
raw paralytic terror that they
physically cannot bear to open the door
while it's still there this is one thing
if it's hiding inside a broom closet but
if you're trapped in a room with only
one exit and 303 manifests behind it you
are in real trouble as the number of
people who have died of dehydration and
starvation in totally normal rooms while
boxed in by 303 have found out when
you're dealing with this monster any
room can be a nightmare but while 303 is
no doubt scary it's not quite as
mind-melting as scp-970
the final anomalous room on this list
much like 303 it involves doors and
rather than being fixed to a single
location it can appear in theoretically
any room known as the recursive room
stepping through this door will lead to
a copy of the room you were just inside
a little trippy but not exactly pure
nightmare fuel but much like how a
photocopier will slowly create
distortions if the same image is copied
repeatedly the more rooms in the
recursive room sequence that one cycles
through the more distorted each one gets
eventually the rooms will begin to
display visuals straight out of your
worst nightmares foundation researchers
who sent a drone through a six-hour
sequence of recursive rooms ended up
being discharged to undergo psychiatric
treatment after seeing their own
mutilated corpses in the rooms a cruel
trick or a deadly phenomenon of things
to come in a darker possible future
either way these unfortunate researchers
couldn't get their experience in the
recursive room out of their heads but
we're sure you'll have a more pleasant
time there you have it folks some of the
most terrifying rooms that the scp
foundation is aware of let us know which
one was your favorite down in the
comments and of course be careful if
these are the ones the foundation has in
containment imagine the ones that are
still out there waiting to be discovered
for all you know it could only be one
door away now go check out
scp-2317 the devourer of worlds a door
to another world and scp-54
the skin salesman demon dan's discount
homunculus depot for more anomalous
doors that should never be opened